my whole thing with frame is you got to
know who you are before you before you
invite anyone else into it
um
you know i just moved to this new city
on the other side of the country in the
u.s
and i'm here for a limited time
i travel a lot for work so
you know when i'm in town i want to have
a good time
and uh i've been seeing this check a
little bit younger than me for a couple
months
she said she sat me down had the uh what
are we talk
and i was just like look i'm here to
have a good time and you know i think
you're wonderful i've had a blast with
you but i'm not looking for anything too
serious right now
and uh lo and behold she was like all
right
not not feeling this right now wanted
something how old was she
she
20 she's 22.
okay with me too at the time all right
uh
didn't talk to her for three months
you know kind of felt bad that it ended
so abruptly but then
lo and behold you know about a month ago
at two o'clock in the morning i get a
drunken booty call and now she's coming
over in two hours so
you know
you just gotta hold your frame and
realize that they're going to try to you
know bring you into their society
yeah it's um
yeah it's a really good point because i
mean like you made your
intentions and your expectations clear
she said that didn't work for her so she
bounced but she decided to come back
when it worked out for her though right
i mean you know you then became
a better option or an acceptable option
a few months later
rich
you also got a set precedent from very
early on
what what i've noticed like what you
said in one of your
one of your clips is like you know i'm
off to put my dent in the universe when
you first meet girls on dates off the
apps and they'll say what are you
looking for i said i'm not really
looking for anything i got my plan i
know where i'm going i know what i'm
doing i said you want to get in the
passenger seat and come along for the
ride it's going to be fun let's see
where it goes and so because you got to
say like well i you know you don't i'm
looking for the one true love i want a
girl that i can drink hot coffee with on
crisp fall mornings and put a sweater
around no dude i'm about my [ __ ] and
you'll if you want to come you will be
entertained with me and they want an
adventure and
and
derek made an excellent point you got to
know who you are
one of the benefits of joining the
community and speaking about younger
guys like moth is i've kind of embraced
my
you know phrase i used for myself
earlier i've kind of embraced all that
you know
billboard meets jared butler in a
rom-com and i love it and girls seem to
like it too
yeah
um jaren did you get your mic working
again
yeah there's a major delay something's
going on with that
he might as well be on the planet
neptune
he's got the spinning wheel of death
happening right now
it just crashed
all right um
i wanted to ask chad because i think
i've had some good chats with chad on
like my stereo show
and i think derek there's an echo on
your end if you go on mute yeah
this is something that chad and i talk
about a bunch and i think this is
something that is really permeating the
space and just in general this idea
about
uh they need to be more emotional they
need to be more vulnerable etc etc
i would love to hear chad's perspective
because i know that it's changed from
like day one or early weeks of dating to
now
where you know it's why don't you open
up more why don't you talk about this
more this and that or tell me what's
going on because chad is if you guys
don't know he runs business he's a very
successful guy so um i'd love to kind of
hear his take on on how he's maintained
frame um throughout this ltr
there's uh you know you would think um
over a long period of time there might
be some more
you know emotional talks and stuff like
that
but there's less
it's actually less i literally i'm like
this is how it's going to be this is
what's going on
this weekend is you know this weekend
we're going here or we make a plan or
whatever but as far as like
um
you know she'll ask me you know of
course i mean i've known her for four
years she'll ask me you know how's your
day stuff like that and i'll be like
awesome or you know well they went to
[ __ ] but i'm turning around and you know
by the end of the day the
the ship will be going in the direction
i want it to go because
you know if it
if every day is perfect i mean come on
that's not reality
so i'm willing to say yeah my day was
shitty today but i got it turned around
no big deal how was your day you know
but
any emotion
in the relationship
is projected by her
i bring i i focus on bringing emotion
out of a woman any any girl that i've
ever that i date you know
since i've come into this space
six years ago um
i focus on the emotional connection
because like i like we had said before a
woman wants to be in a fairy tale they
want to be in a love story
and
you being the emotional tampon of that
arrangement
is not
a fairy tale for a woman
so for me it's
you know holding the frame being
masculine this is what i'm doing this is
where i'm going get on the ship it's
sailing with or without you kind of
thing
that has been through the whole
relationship and any time i mean i
literally pay attention any time
that i've just had a bad day and i'm
being in a bad mood or whatever
she completely changes her countenance
the way she acts the way she talks the
tone of her voice
will change a woman literally if she's
in your frame
her whole entire emotional state will
change with your emotional state
changing yeah so the more you can be
then
yeah the more that you can be that rock
you're a [ __ ] mountain nothing is
going to move you you sh the world could
collapse you're going to rebuild it you
still got this man meteors coming to
strike the earth yeah i got that don't
worry about it i got this yeah that's
the thing and so and it because it's all
about emotion
if there's no explanation there's no
logic there's no nothing it's all about
emotion and the emotional response you
bring out of a woman that's it you uh
touched on something that was
interesting there for a second i mean
like you were talking about like
managing the frame and uh like even
something as simple as
i'm not a talkative guy you know when it
comes to just like small chat blah blah
blah [ __ ] you know like how was your
day what did you think of the weather
today and da da da da and it's like yeah
i don't have those conversations so like
early on for me it's it's it's straight
up like you know
hop on a quick you know phone call to
coordinate something if you need to or
it's like basic conversations with with
text but none of this hammering back and
forth all night long for hours i mean
who's got time for that when you got
[ __ ] to do right yeah and then you don't
have anything to talk about when you
take them on a date on the weekend
because you're right you freaking put it
all out during the week yeah
i mean that if you want if you want an
advanced game for an ltr stop [ __ ]
talking so much yeah
i mean good lord guys be a little bit
mysterious guys you know it's it's
definitely gonna help you more than it
hurts you for sure yeah let me grab some
of these super chats frame really is
everything ultimately
what's that
i said apply that two-thirds rule yeah
exactly that's the um uh 16 commandments
of poon frame really is everything
ultimately game is a demonstration of
one's ability to maintain a mental point
of origin you cannot fake congruence
work on you first much love thanks
brother appreciate that
you